it's a tricky question isn't it and it's
it's so abstract it's very difficult
even once we work out the right answer
to determine what is it that I've just
what did I just answer like I didn't
even know okay so let's try and walk
through it and then hopefully the next
few minutes you with me together
determines what we've done let's read
out a question and then I'm going to put
down the relevant information on the
board a population n of T now by the way
very quickly I think if you're like me
as you start to work out this question
you start to forget what any of these
things mean they just become letters
right and you start thinking index laws
of how to ship things around and soul
simultaneously and so on I think it's
really important that you always have at
least it's somewhere in the back of your
mind what is it that these letters stand
for I mean this is a population and this
is a time right it's not a complicated
idea but many of you I've when you've
gotten the right answer at the end and I
say no what is that and the end the
answer me I'm gonna give me there itself
okay so for those of you is four or five
you who have already gotten all the way
down to the end of puppy okay your real
question to eat up I wonder if you can
answer it before I get to the end is
what have we just calculated for Part A
and for puppy okay population in varies
you type according to the law and they
give you this equation which matches
which matches exponential growth
indicate okay so that's why it comes on
to this topic right and then they give
you some some markers so C and K
positive clusters so they are some kind
of real number and T is greater than or
equal to zero by the way even though
these both seem like restrictions I'm
keeping them separate why think think
why are they separate think back to some
questions if you're doing recently
ckt I'm not the same category a pretty
room right what are they seeing kr
constants right which is why I locate
them in a set of numbers and I say look
these guys there are number in there I
don't know what they are but it's an
actual number and it fits those
characteristics whereas when I go 40
well that's a variable okay so do not
confuse those okay great let's move on
part a show that if now I'm gonna give
you the fancy notation for this even
though you don't have to write it like
this at least you want to be able to
interpret it okay and be a two positive
numbers 2 positive numbers so they
belong to that set as well such that
such that in set notation that's a colon
such as a plus B equals 1 okay so now
I'd not only have a range for where
these guys are but I also have a
connection between them okay what I want
to show this awkward-looking result
the B for any T you okay stop for a
minute busy good for you those of you
who work out the answer already T and
you what are they do what I do then
they're numbers but they're more than
numbers aren't there they're being fit
into here they are times right T is on
we used to be give T is time now just
put in you because they want another
time right so this is literally I'm
gonna say that's sometime in some point
in time and this is another one okay do
you need to know that that's what they
are in order to manipulate there's no
but if you want to understand what's
going on than you do so this is what I
want to show what do you think it's
easier to do go from the left hand side
through the right or the right hand side
to the left what do you reckon which way
have you guys want it looks like it's
easy to start from the right okay
because n of T is too fine for me and if
you not too fine but I can very easily
get it okay so that's where I'm going to
begin right hand side I'm just gonna
write it as is right so here's my wine
okay so now I just got to go to my
definition for what it is right and
substitute that in with T and you okay
so I've got C e to the KT here and I've
got C e to the K you there okay now
remember when you're head towards okay
what is this this is going to be C e to
the K all of that right that's
everything that's going to be up there
in the power okay so that's where I'm
headed towards well I simplify this
what's going to happen well just your
index law you see
whoops sorry c e to the kt a right and
ce2 the K B now what can you do at this
point where can you go don't forget you
have some relationships in here don't
you for instance you know that a plus B
equals 1 right and so because you've got
these B multiplied by each other you're
going to expect that a and that B to
become a plus B right how am I gonna put
it together and I rearranged
I should take a see I should know
okay sorry that see should have an a as
well and no beautiful what do I have
with the see right well I've got C a and
C B right so that's really just a plus B
it's a tip okay are there's the one that
I'm expecting
then I've got all the e terms right I'm
gonna add all of their indices together
like so is that okay
so that there is C to the power of one
it's just C okay in order to make it
clear right because what I'm trying to
prove is a foregone conclusion right so
it's all in the working of right it
ought to make it clear that this is
exactly what I want
I should probably take that Kant K out
should know right what's going to be
left in here it's gonna be this phrase
up here 18 plus UV go I'm done more or
less I just need to rewrite it in terms
of the left hand side that's the
population at that time it's an awkward
looking time isn't it but that's what it
is that's okay pops I've gone from right
inside to left hand side good I'm done
okay party no problems just be careful
with you next now Part B okay they give
you this information they tell you this
and they tell you this and they want you
to find this okay hmm I'm still posing
the question to you what does for
instance this line which you've just
proven what does it prove hmm and how
does it relate to this keep your onion
I'll give you a little more time to
think how do I bring this information to
bear on what I have just proven and
getting the answer out what am I gonna
solve for what do I have to find
I've got two equations here right so I'm
expecting probably there are going to be
two unknowns what are they a and B right
I don't know what these constants are I
know they add up to one but I don't know
why any other information now okay but
if I choose my values for these other
numbers in here well then I'll get an
equation now right so for instance let's
go at the right hand side because I can
see an M 3 and 18 some places I can slot
those in okay
the right hand side would look something
like this let's see let's call this T
and this you write so I have M 3 here to
the power of 8 x + 18 ^ B okay that's
the right hand side what's the left hand
side T is 3 U is 18 right so I'm getting
let's see what is this 3 oops
3 8 and 18 B is that all right those are
just these numbers over here can you see
how it's parallel to we just worked out
so possibly good okay now I know what
these are right that's a ten and that's
a hundred right okay
hmm can I do anything with this where am
I going to go what kinds of things I
need I need to put these together in a
simple form right it's a bit obscure but
I can do it this year I need to find a
and B how am I gonna do it what kind of
equation are we gonna get so well okay
I've got some time equations equations
up here I've kind of used them but this
is own is not enough right what am I
gonna do with it what conclusion can I
draw from this line what is this equal
to 13 why are you gonna why are you
jumping to that why why are you saying
this on what grounds
it's because it's a simple answer right
but it's for those of you who've gotten
stuck around here right it's because
that's what I want that's all it's just
what I'm after right so Abby I'm just
going to choose convenient values that
will get me to this value okay so now I
have an equation I guess I'll call this
to me okay I mean one more to go solve
this but they gave it to us from the
beginning right what are we gonna use f
must be being equal to one okay so there
are two equations just in a and just in
B okay now you can put them together I
think you get do you get a to the third
where's the two-thirds which one is it
hey zip it yeah hey equals 1/3 and B
must equal to 2/3 okay all right yeah so
now what you've got you come back up to
here you can say n of 13 right because
that's what happens when you put these
values of a and B into there do you get
30 is going to be 10 to the power of
occurred times are hundred to the power
of 2/3 right
but of course 100 is just 10 squared 10
squared so this is really 10 to the
power of 4/3 and then you just use your
index laws okay you get to them right
I'll ask you the question again does
this seem like a reasonable value the
problem at this point the reason why
when most of you sort of gave me a
sideways glance when I am a this is
because you don't know if it's a reason
value because you don't know what any of
this means
so have you had enough time to try and
settle the meaning the purpose of all
this in your mind yeah tell me what this
line is tell me what this line is what
is it what are these two things they're
x so therefore that write each of those
is a population at a certain time that
okay these are both populations at
certain times what's this guy
well if this is a time and this is a
time another time
this is this is still another time right
so this is another population at a
different time
what's this tell you it tells you if you
know the population at three times I can
tell you the population add another
right let me draw it for you okay it's
an exponential it fits this kind of
shape right so you're getting you're
getting this what's the initial
condition look at it what's the neutral
condition see right okay now what they
provided to you in Part B is the
population at time three and the
population at time eighteen let's plot
that time is over here okay so time
three might be here then six nine twelve
fifteen eighteen they're about so
they've said look here it's population
10 mm right let's call it a logarithmic
scale and then it's sort of okay right
there you go two populations at two
different times and then they asked you
now what is the population in the middle
somewhere
right when I say that was 15 was it so
somewhere somebody like this
okay so what you proved in Part A was a
relationship between two points in the
curve any two points you like and a
third point and that should make sense
once you know two spots on the curve you
should be able to define the whole thing
right because you know beforehand what
kind of um what kind of grade Ian's
gonna have and how it helped come up
with okay so then you've worked out an
intermediate population given two other
points on either side of it okay and I
wonder if is in population and kind of
control people population study and
country what they call anyway they use
these kinds of models all the time
because of course you know when they say
all the population of the planet is
going to be twelve billion such as such
a point of time how do I know that they
haven't got enough time machine right
well they've got records they have
records right and they can use that to
predict this you can see just as easily
I could have picked a value of time over
here and I would get value okay too you
know huh yeah it is have a look at all
the things we did we did some index laws
what's that you know we did some
simultaneous equations also you know
maybe ten okay now why is it so hard why
was it so difficult it's very abstract
isn't it your final answer out here ends
up being about 46 which which sort of
does it's at least it's in the ballpark
if you have something more than 100 or
less than ten you know that you're wrong
right
it's okay work out your areas are that's
fine